i gotta pull up this article from
post-millennial this one is you're gonna
love it you're gonna love it oh yeah
watch elderly masked white women yell
black lives matter while assaulting
black men for not wearing a mask that's
it that's the story
this is i can't believe this is a video
i don't know uh exactly where the video
came from but um i saw it on libs of
tick tock on on twitter
and you have you can see these women
apparently what happened was this black
dude gets in an elevator and i wear a
mask these two white women wearing masks
yell at him to get out and he's like no
i was here first you get out
they start attacking him they hit him
and he's like yo you hit me and then all
of a sudden she goes black lives matter
what black and the other one goes black
lives matter it's like
it's like
yo
you hit a black dude on camera and you
think yelling that is is gonna help you
these ladies are holding up their phones
they know all about the karen thing but
here's here's the funny thing
these are the mask wearers
they're not supposed to be the karen's
right
or are they like it's weird that it
happened because the karens were the
people who were the right wing you know
the trumpers the anti-vaxxers they were
the ones who refused to wear the masks
in supermarkets now it's literally
it's flipped yep the cairns are the
white people wearing the masks we saw
that lady on the airplane when she hit
the guy yeah i think she's or she's
spitting his mouth yeah
she's spinning as well
yo but i just wanna i think you know
outside of that
are we really at the point where old
white liberals think they can just yell
black lives matter after hitting a black
guy and that like a like that's their
strategy
yeah i remember a girl driving her car
in a crowd of people and it's just like
a black girl i don't i don't call people
i don't like calling people black and
white firstly because we're not white or
black we have skin colors and it's
ridiculous to call people black and
white but this woman was driving her car
and people were like banging on the car
and then they reported they realized
that she was a black girl and then
they're like oh everyone can't stop let
her through black lives matter video
yeah i don't remember exactly how that
played out but that was disturbing man i
mean this is this is the
the signal that we've sent through the
culture i mean from particularly from
you know summer 2020 is if you say black
lives matter or you put up your little
sign in front of your house or or in
your uh your business
it's you know it makes people know that
you're on the side of of the righteous
sometimes i would joke my wife and i
said to me
again to borrow some you know sort of
biblical imagery it's like smearing the
blood on the doorposts so the death
angel passes over um so that people know
look i'm i'm one of the good ones i
think black lives matter let me play
this because the video didn't pull up
but i want to
listen to this get out yeah
go stop get out get out what are you
guys doing get out of here what are you
guys doing yeah
don't touch me don't you have to do that
get out of here
wait again
like i would understand
if there's like two white people
fighting
and they're filming each other and then
one of them yells black lives matter
trying to be like if anybody sees this
i'm on the side of the of the cult right
but they hit a black guy and then yelled
it and i'm like that makes it 10 times
worse
that's incredible i think this is like
peak virtue signal because they're like
i'm gonna actually assault someone who's
actually black but i'm gonna say these
magic words and it'll be nothing bad
will happen to me i also think this is
one of the
unspoken symptoms of long covet quote
unquote
the the neuroses and the anxiety and the
fear
have done almost as much damages as if
not more damage than the disease itself
because this is how
people act when they see
you know like you just see a face
oh oh oh my gosh you know
that that type of anxiety is is not good
look at this picture let's pull just
pull up the article again like look at
this face my eyes yeah yeah yeah it's
crazy to me that
i i just this lady's got no chill i know
this is you know it's the way you're
saying is so true about long long covert
having this psychological because you
can't quantify it like you can quantify
the bank account and like inflation and
we can all agree and point at the number
but with psychosis you got to just you
see it play out like you got to kind of
call it out when you see it yeah it's
going to be unpacking decades of trauma
for people and and part of this is
driven by policy right just just like
the cities that impose the vax past um
the vaccine passport mandates now you're
putting
five to 120 pound year old young women
um
in the position of playing bouncer at a
restaurant and if you do that in a city
that's big enough you're gonna have some
bad reactions because everybody's
already on edge so now when i come you
know let's say i'm out to celebrate you
know my mom's birthday and i'm in a
party of 20 and everybody else gets in
and now you're saying sorry sir you
can't come in because you don't have the
passport and i'm just like well look
here i got a negative test oh we don't
we don't take that
now you're setting people up to have
very very bad interactions with people
over
again policies that obviously are not
working the way that politicians
intended i feel like
within my soul there is this feeling
watching this video of these ladies
and and like to express the pure like
it it is the is a perfect spiral of all
of the bs it is it is the leftist
violence it is the mask karen's it is
the covid policies
all just compressed into one point ready
to just into the worst elevator into one
elevator
and i'm just like if there is any video
you need to share with your friends and
family people often say to me tim my
parents don't want to listen they don't
believe it just go to post millennial
pull this video pull this out
get the tweet
send it to them and ask them what they
think and then they're going to be like
whose side are you on
the mask people who are hitting a black
guy yelling black lives matter who
apparently are the black lives matter
supporters
or the dude who's refusing to wear the
mask
what the heck
it's you know what i find fascinating
about it is it it creates like a this
position
where if you're uh if you're if you're
intellectually honest if you're
principled it's really really simple i
don't care about the race of the guy i
care they shouldn't have attacked him
right i'm not a fan of mass mandates
these people are crazy but if you're on
the side of black lives matter with the
mask karen's you're in a you're in a
pickle here this guy i did notice he
seemed to flick at the girl right when
the video started it's kind of out of
context because it starts in the middle
of the argument for all i know he could
have screamed at him before they started
recording probably unlikely yeah but
come on listen he kind of flicks so it i
don't want to blame either one of them
for starting it it looked like they were
just kind of you listen to each other to
the dude filming and he is he's chilled
out he's confused yeah he's like what
are you doing like why are you doing
this they're angry yes
yeah that's that anger man and he's also
like stuck in the elevator has to get to
where he's going so he's like dude i
can't this is beyond me at this point
poor guy man
this is like uh one other video that i
really like to uh uh um
uh bring up is when the guy was
following the winner on the supermarket
and he said is anyone else mad that we
have to wear masks and she isn't wearing
hers because it's not about covet it's
about authority about doing as you're
told it's obedience
it's funny
uh i call
masks obedience masks particularly in
front of my kids
um my daughter who's six will always
respond it's not an obedience mask dad
uh so i mean it's like a running joke my
wife probably doesn't like it but i mean
that's that's really what it is it's
it's a it's about compliance it's not
about the virus at this point it's about
i feel like i have well i feel like i
have to wear it and i feel bad when i
see people who are flowering these laws
or these mandates or these orders that i
feel like i'm stuck with and that's
really what it is at this point going
back to what we were talking about with
like bill maher and stuff you know why
i'm not a fan of that conversation i'm
willing to bet that bill maher and barry
weiss they they look at the polling
they're like parents are tired of this
the polling for biden's in the gutter i
can tell when the ship is sinking i'm
getting off but bill's interesting he i
remember 2001 after 911 he was like a
vocal advocate for like against the
establishment he was really a show i
think was politically correct
and he was like relentless and they
canceled it they cancelled his show like
he was like a full-on like what's the
guy's name said the seven words that
that comedian uh george he was like full
on the embodiment george carlin i still
get that from him but
then he was gone then he came back yeah
and now he's a little bit toned down
real time is a little more toned down um
he's getting older but i still love that
i feel that like rap that rebel in him i
got to be honest you know i work a lot
uh i do the morning show i do the night
show and with luke leaving the show i
get it luke does his own show too he's
got his channel and so he was he was
working nearly as much as i was
but uh you know to a certain like i'm
also we're also running the business and
expanding so there's a little bit extra
there's a bit more that i do but now i'm
thinking you know luke's on the road
he's going to be in florida he's going
to be working on his morning shift he's
got all that free time at night i can
totally understand at a certain point
you're like
yo i've worked so hard endlessly for the
past several years
for me i'm like no no we got to keep
pushing we got to keep fighting because
there's things that i care about and
things i believe in bill maher however
i can already tell he's a boomer how old
is he 60 or something i think 62. also
and
uh not polish and i was looking up his
he's not political oh like i don't know
why that that's relevant to what i'm
talking about
mother and irish father just so you know
that i know
well ashkenazi is eastern european isn't
it that's what i'm talking about
irrelevant i hope they're related anyway
my point is that it's very obvious he's
checked out yeah it's very obvious like
when the covington scandal happened he
he came out and he was just wrong about
it and i'm like yo we corrected the
story a week ago cnn came out a week ago
and bill maher's a week late still wrong
and people were like cheering for it i'm
just like
i don't think the show is actually about
what's true and correct i think it's
about what's polling and i think you
know with a story like that it's
entirely possible he was like i know
it's not true but this joke's going to
play really really well with this
audience so let's do it yeah a year
later we're supposed to be happy that as
the ship sinking we all got off the ship
let me put it this way try not to be as
trying to be too disrespectful to people
who are at least saying something good
but there's the titanic in it and it's
shin's coming down and as soon as the
iceberg is it hits we all said hey
everybody hit an iceberg time to get in
the lifeboat
and everyone else said shut up you crazy
right winger conspiracy theories there's
no iceberg nobody nothing can see the
titanic right so we're like so you guys
don't care we'll take this lifeboat get
out of here you crazy he said all right
we'll take it yep bye now as the ship's
crumbling and sinking they're all good
oh uh uh we we need lifeboats too we've
been saying it the whole time and i'm
just like the only reason they're saying
it is because it's safe for them to say
it now because the polling's in their
favor they weren't brave enough to speak
out risk getting canceled or fired or
insulted or smeared at the time but
they're willing to say it now so when
bill maher comes out and he does the
virtue signal joke about vaccination and
i'm like ah
they did market research and found we
were right the whole time and now
they're realizing there's an opportunity
for him he got covered it changed that
changed him a lot after he got shot
yeah he got vaccinated and then he got
covered and was like what is this all
about and that then he kind of changed
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you